cette loi elle promulguée est-ce que
vous pensez que cela peut éteindre la
mobilisation ou pas la colère est là 93%
la 93% des actifs cette Français sur 10
le 11 manifestations 3 mois de de
mobilisation tout le champ social mais
on dit beaucoup Paris mais aussi les
préfectures les sous-préfectures comparé
à d'autres réformes des retraites qui
concernaient des entreprises à fort taux
de syndicalisation et donc des centres
urbains c'est partout donc c'est une
lame de fond pour vous et ça ne
s'arrêtera pas d'ailleurs on nous a
expliqué qu'avait l'utilisation du 49-3
le débat les plier et le gouvernement
pensait que le pourrissement et que les
manifestations à les rassembler plus que
100 et quelques personnes comme leur
cabinet occurrence le disent à chaque
fois et pourtant depuis l'utilisation du
carha F3 c'est une marée humaine qui
continue à déferler et les gens ne
veulent pas payer deux ans de leur vie
pour satisfaire les marchés financiers
et quel que soit la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et s'il venait à le
valider comme votre question ça
continuera ça continuera et la colère ne
s'éteindra pas donc il faut une issue
politique et non pas une issue de la
répression policière une issue politique
c'est le retrait ou le référendum on
redonne la parole au peuple français
[Musique]